in fact mills the the principal
investigator uh in his email to steve
kirsch said um
i actually think the result is positive
and it shows a 17 reduction in
hospitalization and if we had only
randomized a few more patients i i
believe that it would have come out
significant so this is literally his
quote this is this is
stunning
the principal investigator on this trial
this trial which has been
heralded from the rooftops as suggesting
that this drug has no effect the
principal investigator believes that the
trial showed
that it was not effective because they
didn't have enough patience that the if
they he believes they saw an effect yep
right and that if they had randomized
more patients that that effect would
have been such that the conclusion would
have been different that is an amazing
thing to be true coming from the primary
author on a paper that the wall street
journal is telling us says ivermectin
doesn't work
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast i am dr brett weinstein and i am
sitting today with alexandros morenos
who
is the ceo of belena who has been doing
a deep dive on the recent or recently
revealed together trial ivermectin arm
we are going to talk through that work
today
welcome alex
hi good to be here
uh so i should probably tell the
audience
that we have become friends i became
aware of you at the point that you
showed up in the early days of the dark
horse live streams and the dark horse
uh discussions with
robert malone steve kirsch
pierre cory etc
there was a lot of criticism at the time
of the dark horse podcast and you
who i now understand are a
a member of the rationalist community
maybe you're a recovering rationalist
i'm not sure but in any case you showed
up and volunteered to
build a protocol to see whether or not
the dark horse podcast was any good at
analyzing
scientific work surrounding covid and
its various potential treatments i must
say that when you emerge to do that work
with the project that you called better
skeptics i believe you were responding
to
heather's suggestion that we need better
skeptics in the world
when you showed up to do that work i was
um
not happy about it because your method
involved scrutinizing transcripts of the
dark horse podcast and while we
certainly endeavor to say
things that are true and to correct any
errors transcripts always make a person
seem like an idiot you know the way we
talk is not the same thing as the way we
write it doesn't have the same level of
care and precision and so
i was concerned about you doing that but
um suffice it to say
you did an admirable job you set up the
thing but you also had referees who were
not used so uh it was independent um do
you want to just quickly say what you
found so that uh we can put that behind
us and get to the together trial sure
yeah so
that
um so so the the back story there was
that i um
i was
you know i i was a listener of dark
horse i had a good
uh
impression of yuri at the time when i
saw the two sort of
collide right i saw i was like okay this
is interesting now right because
you know try to fact check like what
comes out of official sources or
whatever that's
a far more fraud situation here we have
some people who have you know good track
record um and they're
in conflict and that's that's actually
something that's you know
worth worth digging into so we did that
that that project and the reason i had
some
confidence that the transcripts are not
as bad as
you might immediately think is because i
had already i was already challenging
people on twitter just to
say exactly what the problem was because
i was hearing ambient you know the hate
was kind of like
you know faceless and hard to sort of
pin down so i was like all right like
i'm willing to you know
i don't know what i believe here in this
in this conflict like
what can you point me to somewhere and
and i had people sort of start pointing
me in various directions look at this
minute look at that minute and i'm like
it doesn't say what you think it says
and i literally
started typing down it was a steve kersh
quote where i thought okay if anybody
said anything outrageous in the in the
kirsch malone uh
uh darkhorse episode that would be kirsh
and i look at it and it's like no he
actually used three separate qualifiers
and he said exactly what he meant to say
and that was a great expression if you
you know if you bleach it there's
nothing left of the quote but like
random words that you put in succession
sure but that's not what he said so then
i was like you know what i i think the
transcripts are going to be pretty good
i didn't i didn't read them closely um
but i i think i got a good ear like i
catch when people are saying outrageous
things i i catch it in real time and i'd
heard all the stuff so
i was like i i had had a background
confidence that whatever it was it
wouldn't be something like blatant
um and you know i mean what we caught in
the end there was like two or three
things that got caught um
one was that
because we also did we did four podcasts
one of them was your appearance with
pierre corey on joe rogan
and we he mentioned that
you know the who is still minimizing
airborne transmission and technically
speaking
six weeks later earlier or four weeks a
few weeks earlier the who had reversed
its position
now you can debate whether you know what
minimizing means uh but
and and honestly like
[Music]
are we expecting pierre to be like on
the on the daily with like the the wh
but you know actually it was it was a
catch right or there was another one
about zimbabwe where he had i believe
uh personal sort of contact with with
jackie stone over there and he had a
his you know he repeated some things
that
i i could find hints but i i also did
not participate in the challenge so uh i
just let it come through and it's true
that the zimbabwe situation was not as
clear as as maybe pierre presented it
um there was a few of those that we that
we caught but there wasn't
uh there wasn't something that was
uh
you know honestly i think
this is gonna sound strange
i think if the people who were trying to
find claims were were less rabid
were had paid like more careful
attention if i was trying to do that i
would probably have found
uh more things but my sense is that they
will be in that range of like
normal sort of things you might say that
are a little bit out of date or that
you know were
like just like broadly justifiable but
maybe not correct but but the
you know we're talking about four
pockets right we're talking about 11
hours of spoken word just like put that
in context you get one clip of cnn and
you find more stuff wrong than we found
in 11 hours so
that was shocking to me i was sure i was
really really expecting a lot more yeah
i was expecting more too just because it
is spoken word it's not
something that one has written and then
gone through to tighten it up and so
anyway i was i was very pleased with how
it came out and i was
struck by
the fact that you were able to
do a a good and what i thought was a
fair job
even given a mechanism that i thought
was destined to you know flag many many
very minor errors and not be able to
calibrate their interpretation but let's
put that behind us for the moment except
to say
that what we are going to do today is in
some sense
you continuing down
the same road which is to take things
that are contentious in public and
evaluate what's really there and what
its meaning is and what we're going to
do is we're going to look uh at
the together trial which is a very
strange scientific phenomenon in the
sense that its conclusions were revealed
more than half a year ago
the paper that
reports on what is going to be called
the ivermectin arm or maybe it should be
described as the ivermectin arms
was only published recently
in the new england journal of medicine
and so in some sense we've had the
conclusion or the supposed conclusion of
the that arm of the trial for half a
year but have not been able to
scrutinize the methods
or the reasoning that went into
delivering it which is a very odd and
upside down scientific phenomenon now
the way we're going to do this is we're
going to look at the
piece you have just
published you have published it on your
own sub stack so this is not something
that has gone through any sort of
official editorial review nonetheless
you have collaborated with many people
in generating it you have solicited
feedback on it so in in many ways it's
as scrutinized as anything that gets
published given the number of eyes that
have read it and offered critique and
the
ways in which you have fixed it but
nonetheless it's going to be a little
bit of an unusual
dark horse episode it's going to be
challenging for people who are listening
audio only
you are going to
put together a
something like a slide deck
that will allow people to look at the
figures that we are discussing
they can you know scroll through in real
time and you and i are going to be
scrolling through together
um but not on
not on
the screen so anyway you will give
signposts that tell people where to be
looking in this piece and they can look
at it and they can read it for
themselves i will provide links
to your piece to the original new
england journal of medicine publication
and presumably other artifacts like the
wall street journal
article
touting
the publication etc
all right so with that
let us get started where should we begin
we are we are looking at your sub stack
piece which is titled
uh the problem with the together trial
right
um
vanilla title um but you know there was
you know what do you how do you call
this
it's a it's such a big uh big piece you
don't really want to put the conclusion
in the
uh in the title but um the yeah so so i
think the place to start is to
understand what the together trial was i
think you can't really make any sense of
the conversation until you understand
what the together trial especially in
the together trial is ongoing right so
it it in a sense it is but we were
talking about a period of trust several
sort of parallel uh kind of studies that
we're running
and were started in early january so
mid-jan let's say
um and
end of 2021
um you know around the time of the you
know inauguration of the current
president et cetera uh just to put it in
in in in context of you know what was
happening in the world and then it and
the the trial uh ended at least the part
that we're interested in on august 5th
uh and sixth
yeah fifth the declare change and maybe
there's a little bit of tail in the data
maybe we went up to the sixth
so that period of time is what we're
looking at and in that period of time i
have maybe the first diagram here on the
paper is
um
in the in the article is maybe uh useful
um adaptive trials basically run
multiple arms
at the same time right it's a it's a
it's an elegant idea so i'm gonna i'm
gonna try to uh help translate for
people sure sure
uh what we're looking at is a composite
trial where the same investigators were
looking at the effect of different
possible treatments for
covid19
at the same time they were leveraging
a
basically if you're testing multiple
drugs and they're all to be tested
against a placebo you can get a benefit
by
generating a single placebo algorithm
right so you have one
uh placebo generating engine effectively
and you can compare it to all of these
treatments simultaneously rather than
having to do an independent one for each
drug so there's a kind of
economies of scale issue here and the
arms refer to the different substances
or protocols being tested
right
yes um
it's you know it's it's you can you can
think of it as an efficiency in terms of
the the funding you're going to use to
to generate results you can think of it
as an efficiency even in kind of human
lives right you don't want to put too
many people at risk it's a it's an
admirable sort of setup and as i've
delved into it i've gotten sort of
um
you know quite enthusiastic about sort
of the idea but also quite um concerned
about the the knobs that
it it presents
and you know we when we built the rct
system right we put a number of you know
the whole blinding
stuff and there's a lot of rules around
how you do an rct in order to prevent
gaming this is kind of a new
uh generation of of that idea and it
we'll talk through it but my sense is
that it it hasn't matured yet to the
point where we know all of the uh all
the knobs okay so i want to clarify a
number of things i'm going to try to um
stand in for the audience here and ask
the questions i think they will
obviously want or at least some will
want to know when you say rct you're
referring to randomized controlled trial
which many people will have heard many
times during the pandemic is the gold
standard for scientific evidence now
heather and i have challenged repeatedly
whether or not it makes sense to think
of it as the gold standard it certainly
has
a an advantage
which is if it is well done
it is excellent for
taking what may be a very subtle effect
and amplifying it so that you can see it
above the noise it tends to control for
all of the factors that you may not even
be aware are impinging on your trial to
reveal a
an actual effect
that being said it is also an easily
gamed structure that is to say it is
sensitive if the underlying work is
poorly thought out or if there is bad
faith in its structuring which we will
get to so randomized controlled trial is
what you mean when you say rct
and this is a double-blind randomized
controlled trial double-blind
meaning that the whether or not any
given individual
was in
a treatment arm or a treatment group the
treatment group or in the control group
should have been
opaque to both the experimenters and to
the patients so right that is to say the
sense that somebody is getting the drug
and it is working or not working should
have um
not been available as an input right the
people should not have known whether
somebody was getting the treatment or
getting the placebo
darkhorse has a new sponsor with this
episode the spectator
as the longest running magazine in the
world and indeed the known universe the
spectator issues identity politics in
favor of intelligent conversation and
thought
from the war in ukraine to the
ideological war in the classroom from
the rise of inflation to the rise of
cancel culture the spectator has been
dedicated to stimulating reporting and
analysis since 1828.
the spectator also covers the best in
books travel food wine and much much
more
the u.s edition of the spectator has
recently come ashore and is bringing its
high quality writing and analysis to u.s
audiences for the first time
we have a special offer for listeners of
darkhorse
sign up today and you'll receive three
free months of the print magazine and
full digital access
plus they're going to send you a free
spectator hat one great for free
spectators
just go to spectatorworld.com
special offer and use the offer code
darkhorse personally i'm a fan of the
spectator because it is committed to the
quality of its reasoning and writing not
to a particular political party or
ideology
it's got amazing contributors including
douglas murray lionel shriver julie
bendel christopher buckley
roger scrutin and darkhorse's own
heather heing
the spectator is less political party
more cocktail party whether you lean
left or right you are guaranteed to be
entertained informed and enlightened
from cover to cover
so sign up today and get three months of
the spectator for free plus a hat that
you can promise to eat if you're wrong
which you're unlikely to be as a reader
of the spectator
subscribe today at spectatorworld.com
special offer use the code darkhorse at
checkout to redeem your offer that's
spectatorworld.com
special offer and use the code darkhorse
this episode is sponsored by farolife
which makes skin care products from
animal fats you heard me
when you work with your hands your skin
gets rough exposure to the sun and wind
will do the same thing
skin food by feral life is a terrific
solution
a little goes a long way it's made in
small batches here in the u.s and the
fat is a hundred percent sourced from
farms that use regenerative and
pasture-based animal husbandry which
ferrolife calls smartlard technology if
you've got sensitive skin or a baby with
diaper rash or a small child with eczema
or your hands are simply chapped from a
night of grave robbing you should try
feral life skin food
fair life uses no artificial chemicals
or preservatives and the products are
highly effective at moisturizing human
skin
it really does work and it doesn't make
you smell like a girl either not that
there's anything wrong with that
feral life is a young company the first
skin care company of its kind and it is
eager to produce a diversity of healthy
high quality products including soap
deodorant and lip balm after all the
lard works in mysterious ways
here at dark horse we love what pharaoh
is doing and want to see them succeed
when you discover how effective their
products are you will too
apply a little skin food daily to
restore skin health elasticity and
moisture
dark horse listeners can save twenty
percent off their first purchase by
going to faro dot life slash dark horse
or applying the code dark horse at
checkout
additional fifteen 15 savings by signing
up for a subscription to receive pharaoh
skin food on a monthly bi-monthly or
quarterly basis
that's pharaoh.life
darkhorse
all right i'll let you pick up from
there we've got a randomized controlled
trial double-blind proceeding with
multiple arms right as to say multiple
drugs under test against a placebo right
right and that's so the the adaptive uh
sort of uh
sort of innovation on top of the rct
sort of system
so you have multiple uh things running
um and
so so when when the taro started they
were trying metformin which is one drug
that
ended up being cut off early it wasn't
it wasn't uh it didn't seem to be doing
anything um they were trying ivermectin
uh but they tried a dose
that uh you know we we might consider
homeopathic i don't know like it was uh
uh a single dose of 400 mcg per kilogram
um
so and and that was if you are exactly
60 kilos if you're above you go less
wait wait wait wait wait
so when you say homeopathic you're
you're kidding i'm kidding
is that homeopathy which um
let's leave aside what we think of it
but the basic problem as us scientific
and rational folks
uh have imagining that a homeopathic
remedy might work is that the basic
method for generating a homeopathic
treatment is to dilute it
so much that there is effectively
um
no
effectively no trace even at the
molecular level of the drug in question
or the substance in question so when you
say that the initial iremectin
uh protocol involved a single treatment
of what was the dosage uh 0.4 sorry 400
mcg per per kilogram okay 400 mcg per
kilogram in a single dose so anybody who
is aware of treatment protocols that
were being applied by people who
by doctors on the ground knows that
that's way too low
and a single even so the dosage per
kilogram of body weight is low
and a single dose is uh an absurd
protocol in light of what the doctors
who were using this to treat patients
believed worked
um and then you're telling me there's a
third issue there which is i mean yeah
in an attempt to be extremely fair i did
go and look at the flccc protocol at the
time
that the
this protocol was being designed so not
even when it started but when it was
designed the flcc was recommending two
doses of 200 mcg per kg however
this dose did not scale above 60
kilograms so if you're 120 which is
close to my weight you'd get half of
that right and and
it was not with a meal um it was
anyway so even 400 is basically a title
number if i'm trying to guess
the average that a patient would have
gotten in that trial would be more like
250. so so let me let me try to clarify
this
the question uh so first of all people
should know that there is a well
understood problem with what are called
underpowered trials
if you want to do a trial and get no
effect one way to do it is to use way
too little of whatever it is right if
you want to test for example whether or
not
water is a good treatment for
dehydration
and you test a thimble full of water in
a population of 100 people
dying of thirst a thimble full of water
will have some effect but it will be so
tiny that you will have almost no uh
chance of spotting the difference in how
long it takes those you know this is
obviously an absurd example but um
so an underpowered trial is a well
understood thing so one thing you might
do if you were concerned that this was
an underpowered trial is you would say
well what dose did they use and you
would look at this dosage and you would
have a per kilogram measure and you
would say well it's not that
underpowered
okay but the point is if you're only
looking at the amount of ivermectin per
unit of body weight it may not be that
underpowered a single dose is
50 percent of what you're telling me
that the fl triple c
was uh
using at the point the trial was
designed plus
there's a kind of hidden factor here
which is that for reasons that maybe
you'll tell me that they had some
explanation but for reasons that are not
obvious to me they had a 60 kilogram
cutoff so the bigger you were
the lower the dose per unit of body mass
which is strange in light of the fact
that a this is a fat soluble drug and so
people with high bmis might be expected
to have this drug absorbed into adipose
tissue and dropped to very low levels
and then the next thing you're telling
me is that they gave it on an empty
stomach which everybody who was aware of
what a good procedure would have been
for ivermectin is
knows because basically if you want the
ivermectin to stay in your gut
because you have parasites and it is a
very well understood anti-parasite drug
you would take it on an empty stomach so
that it didn't get absorbed into the
body but if you're treating covid you
would want to have it absorbed into the
body so you would take it with a meal
that had fat in it
the
just to pull it all together because i
want to try to be very fair because the
the concern i'm going to raise is going
to be very significant
so if we go back to december 20th the
focccc was not recommending with a meal
in in mid-january it was but they would
have had to revise their protocol to
catch up
anyway um so so it was known at the time
it started but maybe not at the time
that they designed it a month earlier
the the dose ultimately if we if we
unders what we understand of the
demographics of the trial it was half it
was high bmi over 30 half with low bmi
so you can sort of try to to extrapolate
the weights and stuff like that my
senses was that ultimately they gave
about 250 mcg per kg in a single dose if
we just average it out all over all the
patients but under dosing
the the biggest bmi patients who are at
most risk from covet so even that is is
a
is not stating it too it if we i don't
know if we balance it all out probably
that what you said half
uh you know an effective 200 uh mcg per
kg
uh is what you know what would be the
equivalent that you would get you know
with with a lot of extrapolation and
asterisks
okay um so i want to highlight something
else and i can see already how much
trouble there is but in some sense this
is i think what the audience is going to
need to understand is that
the reason that a randomized controlled
trial might be an excellent kind of
evidence
is because it
very powerfully takes everything that
could possibly affect a trial that is
not the treatment
and neutralizes it by getting it equally
into the control group and into the
treatment group
the problem is when you have a protocol
that is so baroque
that and we have watched many people i
don't know how many people have been
looking at this trial to try to figure
out what happened
but we have
what is at least 10 maybe dozens of
people
spending many many hours looking at the
methods and just trying to reconstruct
what actually took place that should
never be
it is vital the the value of something
like a randomized control trial is
completely dependent on the fact that we
can scrutinize the method and say that
if this is what was actually done then
we know what these results mean if we
can't figure out what was exactly done
if it's basically like a criminal
investigation trying to sort out who did
what when what was the dosage that a
person would have experienced right if
we have that level of complexity
the thing is effectively invalid on
arrival
right you can't have something so
baroque that you don't understand the
experiment because it is vital that we
be able to scrutinize it it has to be
able to be pressure tested and if we
don't know what happened then we have to
speculate yeah and and if i may
the the the
the misunderstanding that many of us had
uh early on about the the placebo group
right having different
uh sizes and things and and some people
said online that
uh well you just don't understand
adaptive trials and you know clearly
just they're showing your your lack of
understanding uh that particular feature
that we all got caught up on it was an
innovative feature of this particular
trial
right this was not even among adaptive
trials it was a specific so you know
it's a form that's evolving there was a
lot of complexity in figuring out what
was going on and i think anybody who
says that you should be able to just
like you know just read the paper and
understand i mean i think we'll make it
very very clear as we go through the
work
um but they're they're they're fooling
themselves so
you're talking about the issue where
many of us including me thought that
there was evident in the paper a
number of people who went missing from
the placebo group who dropped out and it
turned out that was not the case right
that was an error in interpretation but
the fact that many people made the same
error suggest that that was at least an
intuitive understanding of the paper as
presented and so this was a natural
misunderstanding right that one has an
innocent explanation sure not all of
these things to do i made the same
mistake and then as soon as i as i
figured out i was going around sort of
trying to uh explain this to everybody
so we don't keep you know saying things
that don't
that were that didn't have validity
because again i do believe there's
actual issues that have reliability
right and so anyway as a general matter
let's just say
let's give them their due
this is a very complex endeavor for many
reasons
it would be impossible to do it without
making mistakes what one hopes is that
the design is robust enough that the
mistakes are not consequential
but some of the things that people have
spotted in this trial turn out to have
innocent explanations or not be very
important others do not appear to have
innocent explanations or not be very
important now that
could be that the
the people who ran the trial didn't spot
the errors
and that they uh would become aware of
them as people scrutinized their paper
the editors should have caught it the
peer reviewer should have caught it but
um that you know it's not so unusual
that something emerges and then
issues crop up
but at some point
the fact that the authors are not
forthcoming with data that would allow
us to figure out for sure that they
don't answer questions that allow us to
nail down exactly what did take place in
their methodology
and that they are
cagey
um or inconsistent in responding to
questions about what they did all of
those things suggest something else and
we'll get there so anyway there are
innocent problems there are other
problems that look not so innocent let's
let's get to them so uh as we said in
the beginning they started with
metformin low-dose hybermectin that
that's how the arm was called in the
whenever they mention it um
fluvoxamine was the other arm that was
on and of course placebo
so they were running a 1 1 1 1
randomization
scheme so basically
it was not exactly like this but just
abstractly you can think as the patients
were coming into the various trial
centers
um they were
evenly allocating them to the four
arms we mentioned so evenly allocating
in a way that would have been blind to
their characteristics they should be
randomly allocated to the multiple arms
of the trial
including the placebo group and the
result of that should be that any sort
of pattern in the way people showed up
should be disrupted by an algorithm that
isn't scrutinizing them in any way is
just simply assigning them to one
treatment or another or to the placebo
group so that should destroy
uh
spurious
correlations that would be in the
clustering of
people somehow yep
so uh yeah so so here's where things
start to go kind of uh interesting so
on the 15th of february uh this is less
than a month into the trial
um there's a protocol that appears the a
new version of the protocol of the trial
uh it's dated february 15th and it's
submitted to the brazilian authorities
on february 19th
for approval for ethics approval to
change how the trial works this is how
you do it right you that's that's a
that's a that's a good practice you
change your protocol and then you send
it to the authorities of the country
you're in to make sure that they're
you're not doing something they don't uh
they don't consider to be correct you
know giving too much giving too little
whatever it is they need to have a need
to have a say um
here's where things become interesting
so that protocol was
recommending stopping the average
mexican arm because the dose was so low
as we said as
to make the results not interesting
essentially right by that time there was
quite a bit of uproar they mentioned
advocacy groups had reached out to them
for whatever reason they said look we're
going to stop
the ivermectin arm the low-dose one and
we're going to start it again with a
higher dose
good
the problem is that they continued
recruiting patients into the dose arm
after they had submitted it to the
brazilian authorities so you now have a
situation where you are recruiting
people into
an arm of a trial that um
you
don't
you probably don't believe that the dose
is going to be affected right so why are
you doing that but even if you did let's
say you say no no i think it's effective
but others don't whatever well you're
going to throw away the data you're
going to stop the trial it's going to be
you know thrown away so why are these
people being you know put into a trial
that you don't think
uh
you know is is gonna amount to anything
and indeed we have not seen that data
the the data of the the arm that was cut
short
we we have no sense of
you know what those numbers were
um so that's i i find it particularly
concerning because you know it's
somebody who's sick uh high-risk patient
uh enters a trial you know you want to
think that you're doing the best
according to your state of knowledge at
the time
and that doesn't i don't i can't
understand how the researchers put
put those two stories together
so um let us say this is a case where
something very odd happened
right
whether that odd thing is consequential
is not obvious right it is perfectly
possible to continue to run an arm of a
study that you know isn't useful and to
never report that data and it it's an
absurd thing to do but it's not
necessarily destructive
of the conclusion that you ultimately do
report based on other patients on the
other hand
one can certainly think of reasons that
you might continue
to recruit or to continue to treat and i
think recruit into that arm of the trial
even though you didn't intend to report
the data right it's not easy to think of
reasons but it's not too difficult
either and we will get to some possible
reasons but ultimately i think the
answer is going to have to be we don't
know and we shouldn't have to speculate
yeah so so yeah just to give a sense uh
before february 15th where the
new protocol is dated there were about
19 patients recruited into the low dose
hypermicron arm after there's 59
patients so the vast majority of the
patients was recruited after they had
already determined to change the
protocol and
who knows when they started talking
about changing the program that's the
date the 15th of february is the date of
the protocol it's on the protocol itself
um anyway so that happens and then on
march
what i estimate is march 4th and this is
by
uh by the way what am i using where are
these numbers coming from that i'm
talking about these are coming from
materials released by the investigators
themselves on august 6. literally one
day after the trial was completed they
came out with the results but you
mentioned that it came out in the summer
so they showed us
a a graph which is kind of the second
visual in in the article
which kind of showed per week how many
patients were recruited into each
arm so that gives us a lot of
information not only about the totals
this graph by the way agrees with all
the publications that put out it's not
sort of inconsistent it's not some sort
of throwaway
the data checks out with everything
they've published in in their papers
um so so we we know quite a bit about
what what the pace of enrollment was in
each
arm
um so so around march 4th based on based
on that data
they stopped the lotus air american arm
there's not an obvious reason why that
was the date
and then around march 15th the brazilian
authorities approve
the uh the new protocol
um in their paper in the new england
journal of medicine they say that
approval came on the 21st of march i'm
not sure why
uh and on march 23rd they start
enrolling
patients in the new uh in the new arm so
the the um
the protocol is declared clinical
trials.gov which is kind of where you go
to make your you know all serious trials
sort of go there to to to to put up
their protocols to make sure that
they've
to have a have a
reas an assurance for everybody that
that protocol was their protocol at the
time right the government sort of
reassuring everybody that they're not
going to let you change that after that
so we know march 21st
what their protocol was and by 23rd they
started enrolling
um
uh patients into what essentially seemed
to be like they rebooted i have a
american trial right which started with
a low dose we cut it short at 77
patients we we had a bit of a break and
then we're starting over with a high
dose higher dose uh
iromatin uh arm while the other arms are
ongoing right so the flvox coming on
from january is ongoing the metformin
arm from january is ongoing and the
placebo arm is ongoing
so
yeah so far so good i will say that uh
you have put together a
easy to understand timeline that has
these things as different strata so you
can see where the low dose arm stops the
gap in time you can see the higher dose
booted up you can see where we think
various approvals and things happen uh
anyway it's all visually presented here
and
let's put it this way there's nothing
you know
there's no reason that them pointlessly
continuing to recruit people into the
low dose arm that's there's nothing
fatal about that
there's nothing fatal about them
discovering that their protocol is wrong
and starting from scratch as long as
they
say here's the period of time in which
we
delivered this dosage etc
but
the question is
is this about something
is there structure to what took place in
here that actually skews our
understanding of what they report or is
this just the difficulty of running a
complex trial and you know discovery
along the way of what you should have
put in motion to begin with um and
anyway
we'll see that but i would i would
advise people who are following along to
look at your timeline to understand
what's taking place
so the
um if we here's here's where so march
23rd is really the day where things
start to go
get really strange
so the third diagram on my on my uh
article
is um i focused on a 10-week period
between february 22 february 22nd
and the week starting april 26th
in that
sort of 10-week period we have two weeks
where
allocation is sort of normal it's the
end of the low-dose hyperactin arm we
have two weeks where there's no
allocation to low-dose hypermectin
because that arm has been stopped which
is normal uh and then we have the first
two weeks of the high dose
hypermechanium and that these are the
kind of the the two weeks where things
start to look really strange so when you
say allocation you're talking about
allocation of new recruits to this trial
these are patients and these are people
who have covet
correct so these are brazilians who have
antigen positive tests so it's not a
it's not a pcr but
and really this is actually maybe
interesting to to mention here this is
done in brazil right um during um
you know the the early 2021 period
everybody can sort of remember here but
there
that's exactly when the gamma wave the
gamma variant wave is sort of at its at
its peak um and the pictures that are
being sort of transmitted even in the
paper you can read in some of the
appendixes about what was going on is
like apocalyptic you kind of get the
picture of a
um early early pandemic italy like
that's my picture in my head people
being hospitalized in corridors you know
facilities being overrun um people
needing to set up you know like
temporary facilities to to to to to work
with the with the volume of patients
that sort of thing um so that's what's
that's what's happening in the in the
surrounding uh
sort of you know world around this trial
so that
uh
i think this is vitally important and
people who are not
experienced thinking about scientific
experimental design are not necessarily
going to intuit this but
the experimenters can do nothing about
the fact that in order to do their trial
they are interfacing with a fluctuating
pattern right we are talking about covet
it's not consistent over time how many
people have it which variant they have
how sick they are getting how people
feel about it which matters because of
course that's part of why we have the
placebo group is that people's
perceptions play into these things
so in effect what we have is a is a
trial
that is recruiting sick people
sick people who have vulnerabilities
comorbidities right
um
and they are being recruited into a
trial it's voluntary right and so
that
the fact of them showing up
is likely the result of the fact that
they want
you know imagine yourself uh facing the
question of should i participate in a
scientific trial of
a drug that might be effective against
covid what motivates a person to do that
well one of the things that motivates a
person to do that is
i'm sick and i'm frightened and if i
enter this trial
there's a 50 chance that i'm going to
get a treatment that
somebody thinks might be effective right
so 75 is adaptive so
so uh so in any case you have people
volunteering to enter the trial hoping
to get a drug that will treat a disease
that they have and are concerned is a
danger to them and the degree to which
they are afraid the degree to which they
are sick and what they are sick with is
changing over the course of this trial
which the experimenters can do nothing
about the background is going to
fluctuate what they can do is they can
make a protocol that neutralizes that
effect right
now how do they do
so this is where this is where things
become strange and i i can find no
explanation as to what happened on that
week that starts march 22nd on march
23rd and the second day
they start recruiting into the high-dose
cyber mechanic now
that week we would expect because all
four arms that we described are act
hydrocyber maximum methamphetamines
luvox i mean placebo we would expect
roughly 25 allocation to each arm
instead what we have and it doesn't have
to be exactly 25 just to be clear like
there can be some fluctuation because
there's there's block randomization
certifications there's reasons why that
might play
but that week we see 57 of all patients
that come in are allocated to the
ivermectin high dose arm this is at the
peak of the of the gamma variant wave
okay in the first the first week of the
the new sort of arm that's started so we
have to unpack here a little bit
um
there are two kinds of error
uh two kinds of uh
error that can creep into an experiment
the randomized controlled trial is
designed to neutralize
the
noise
however to the extent that the
neutralization mechanism is
not effective in actually randomizing
then the point is it actually introduces
structure
right so what you're getting at which is
i think going to be quite subtle for
people
is that the moment in time in which
people enter the study is
predictive in ways that we know and ways
that we don't know of what their
their prognosis will be and so to the
extent that the allocation that the
randomization uh by the algorithm does
not uh is
um
structured with respect to when it
allocates people to what
right
you are going to get a non-random effect
right that is to say if you've got a
clump of people who come in the door at
the same time
then they may be sick with something
less severe they may be sick with
something more severe as long as they're
equally distributed through the various
uh arms it doesn't matter but if they're
lumped then it matters in a critical way
sure and and again think keep in mind
that also the facilities are overrun
which means that people might be getting
less good care
right
ah so this is another i hadn't thought
of this one but this is a this is
another subtle effect which is that as
you get a wave of covid even if they
were sick with the identical thing you
obviously have limited medical resources
and so the more people who are sick at
one time the less good care they would
get the worse their prognosis would tend
to be right so the point is time plays a
critical role here and what one needs is
a bomb proof method for neutralizing the
structure
in time
and uh anyway i know you're going to get
deeper into what happens
yeah this is this is what's called
confounding by time technically right so
so you if you unless your patients are
you know roughly in the same sort of
time time frame um then you are using a
different
this offset itself can introduce the
bias is what you're saying
yep absolutely it can introduce a
critical bias and frankly if the bias
it may sound to people as if
random error
is
worse than systematic error
random error sounds scary but random
error is not a terrible problem uh in
science it can be swamped out by simply
increasing the size of a study
systematic error is the dangerous
thing and we're what we are talking
about here are systematic errors uh the
very reason we do a randomized control
trial right what you were saying before
that this is the at the root of the
motivation of of doing it this way yeah
if we're not doing it this way then
we're not doing it this way it's it's
yeah
all the guarantees that you're getting
are sort of starting to to exit exit the
stage right and so
uh
it is also the case that so you know we
who have
talked about the effectiveness of
ivermectin right who have discussed it
have been faced with the claim
that any evidence that doesn't come
through a large-scale randomized
controlled trial is unimportant and we
must await the large-scale randomized
controlled trial because of its ability
to neutralize these kinds of effects
right we then have the conclusion from
this trial presented more than half a
year before we are able to look at the
methods largest randomized controlled
trial of ivermectin to date discovers
uh that there is no uh effect now we
will talk about whether that's actually
what it discovered but nonetheless
that's what we were told and then there
was a more than half a year delay in our
ability to figure out what was in this
trial and then on looking at what was in
the trial the methods and and what was
done the point is well it wasn't a
randomized controlled trial because the
attempt to randomize was structured in a
way that was ineffective relative to the
background fluctuations so
you know either it doesn't matter by the
way if it was done on purpose or by
accident right we're going to talk about
maybe some explanations about what
could have could have happened though
the explanations are separate from what
did happen and what that means um but it
doesn't have to be on purpose that we're
not necessarily saying that this
particular blip was somebody sort of was
putting their thumb on the scale or
something
we're not saying it wasn't but
there could be reasonable explanation
but what we're saying is that the effect
on the results
is orthogonal is completely separate to
the motivation question well the point
is it looks like a randomized controlled
trial the intent was apparently to run a
randomized controlled trial but if the
randomization fails then you can't say
well this is the gold standard because
it was a randomized controlled trial um
so
effectively the point is what is this
trial evidence of and how should it be
integrated with the other evidence we
have is the question and that the label
on the box saying it was a randomized
controlled trial means nothing if the
randomization wasn't uh effective yeah
so so just to
continue with the with the sort of the
data we're talking about the first week
is 57 percent on high-dose ivermectin
second week uh it's 41 percent high-dose
ever making right and these are the
allocations by the algorithm allocation
to the different arms and and by the way
keep in mind that this means that
uh the other arms are also being under
allocated right so if you got 57 percent
uh
you know just roughly 60 going into one
arm you'll have roughly 15 percent going
to each of the weight
you'll have
40 by three whatever like 13 12
um
going
on average to the other arms right so
the the disparity is is huge like you
know 57 versus 13 something like that or
14 say yes i'm like that
so
uh
i i guess the way for people to think
about this is
imagine just as a thought experiment
that covid was a perfectly uniform
phenomenon in the background that every
week was like every other week with
respect to how many people were sick
what they were sick with how sick they
got how much care they got right if if
there was no variation in the background
uh kovid phenomenon
then the allocation to uh one arm in a
particular week versus the other arms
wouldn't end up having a consequential
effect in the data it still renders the
trial not a randomized controlled trial
but if the background wasn't fluctuating
maybe it would have no impact on the
conclusion on the other hand if one
imagines that some weeks are terrible
coveted weeks and people are sicker
because the doctors are stretched too
thin or the doctors themselves are sick
or
whatever the effect or there's a change
in the variant that's circulating in the
place where the trial is being done and
people are sicker with a worse disease
if that structure exists where some
weeks are worse than others then you can
imagine if the people who were sicker
got
disproportionately loaded into the
high-dose ivermectin arm then it would
make ivermectin look less effective
right because the point is the outcome
that's being measured which in this case
is hospitalization
um would uh people would be hospitalized
for reasons that weren't about the
treatment they were getting they were
it's because that was a sicker week yep
so um yeah so moving on about um what is
it sort of
four or five weeks later uh
the the the allocation balances out
right and it starts to operate in a
fairly predictable way so if you if we
if anybody's following along you see the
next diagram with a curve um you can see
that after uh it was at like april 4th i
believe uh maybe maybe april 8th um
the the the allocation starts being uh
smooth like all the arms are growing at
the same rate
which means that uh you know the kind of
uniform right the algorithm whatever was
going on
the the allocation now has been restored
and it continues being
uh
sort of regular um so we're we're left
with this strange sort of uh
four uh four-ish weeks at the beginning
of the high-dose hyper-magnetic arm
where we had more patients
allocated just even arithmetically we
had more patients allocated to the
high dose hybrid arm and then we don't
have equivalently more patients being
allocated to the placebo arm that is
supposed to be at the same uh period of
time so in their paper that they
published the authors swear up and down
that all the patients that we're looking
at are after march 23rd both for placebo
and for treatment this is
as clear as it gets
um but when we see there there are no
normal arms and there are various
publications for fluvoxamine for uh for
metformin and we we assemble the results
there's there's um the at the end of the
sort of the aeromectin uh trial in
august we have
679 patients forevermectin
okay that's close to what they had said
even though there was some ambiguity but
let's let's grant that um but we have i
believe 604 patients uh on the uh
placebo arm that could be
compared against hypermech yet what they
report
is 679 placebo patients
so there's this weird 75 you know the
ghosts of bella horizonte
you know the the city where most of the
most of the
centers were 75 patients we don't know
um where they came from now there is one
theory
that uh one hypothesis that that fits
everything we know which is that
remember the two week gap we were
talking about before the start of the
high dose i reckon well that's has
that gap has exactly 75 patients
extra in the placebo arm
right
yep
so uh
fill that in what does that imply
so um so so the hypothesis just to be to
to spell it out is that those 75
patients were used
uh so so the placebo arm basically was
taking over a longer period of time than
the uh ivermectin are right you had two
extra weeks at the beginning now those
two extra weeks at the beginning uh when
we look at the case fatality rate from
the from the area had a lower case
fatality rate so it was right before the
kind of burst of the gamma wave gamma
wave that sounds like anyway gamma
variant wave
there was no radioactive no
radiation
to discern anyway maybe i should look at
it um but um uh
so so we have a lower um
case
mortality actually uh in that previous
period right before um there's another
problem and this problem i just can't
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait i
don't want you to go on to your next
problem yet because again this is too
subtle
okay
so
if
the hypothesis is correct that they used
the
placebo recruited patients from an
earlier period than the ivermect and the
high-dose ivermectin patients to whom
they were being compared
then that is a failure of control
right
so we had a failure of randomization and
now we have a failure of control
and the reason that that's a failure of
control and in this case
there are lots of ways this could go but
because the weeks in question were less
severe
coved weeks
it makes the placebo group look
healthier so if you took
the high dose ivermectin patients from a
week when things were particularly bad
they would tend to be sicker and if you
take the placebo patients to whom they
are being compared from a relatively
less sick week then that will tend to
make the drug look less effective
whatever its actual effect is
um
so
that
if it is true
is the second utterly fatal failure here
now
i want to point to a third failure
the obvious thing
is
you say well here's a hypothesis about
where these patients came from you
researchers have published this paper
if those
placebo
controls were
not from this period where it seems
likely they came from then you
researchers have the most incentive of
anybody to simply reveal what the
discrepancy in the data is about
and they should be eager to do it and to
the extent that they are not being
forthcoming about showing their data
that is odd right you have an anomaly
it's not unusual that a paper is
ambiguous in terms of what it presents
but the right remedy the normal
scientific remedy is for a request to be
made to see the data
and for that data to be provided so that
it's clear that there's nothing being
hidden right right and and uh in fact as
per the flu vox mini paper that was
published in i believe october
in the landsat if you look at the data
sharing statement they say you know upon
publication of this manuscript we will
make the data available through some
procedure that you know i have more
questions with but the long story short
is that that didn't happen
there is no access to the data as of
october they said the same
in the publication now in the new
england journal of medicine still not
the case they now in an email the the
the principal investigator said we're
busy because we're submitting a eua for
this other drug that succeeded and you
know
we'll do it
basically but but that will go to some
somebody
that you have to submit a research
proposal and that body inc in
coordination with the investigators will
review and approve
this was not what was promised
originally they said upon request upon
termination right when we're done
ask for data you know if you look legit
we'll give you the data um that's not
what's happening and actually not none
of those two things it's not a
contamination right so we're still
waiting and um the process is looking
starting to to acquire hoops to to to
jump through which
look
we are well
look i hate to use this metaphor maybe
it's unfair um although
maybe it isn't
you know you say well um
uh this that you've published does not
add up as it is
can i see the data and they say do you
have a warrant right i mean it
the the question is why are they not
providing the data they should be eager
to do it because the fact is it would
become obvious if the mistakes are
trivial
it would become obvious if there are
mistakes that are not trivial but they
are uh made in good faith that's not
fatal but what is fatal is
things that cannot be reconciled in what
they published and a refusal to clarify
what generated those anomalies yep
yeah and and um
so
and and it should be noted right that
this is happening in a in a period of
time and in a specific sort of molecule
that's being investigated
that has attracted a lot of scrutiny and
to the degree that the studies are being
scrutinized and and bad science is being
found out i i absolutely have no
objection personally um we've all
learned a lot about what to trust and
what not to trust we've gotten more
skeptical as a result
i i you know
i subscribe to that to that program
i do not subscribe to the claims that
were made on the basis of those findings
that the entire research of that field
is now a fraud or you know these kinds
of things because it actually when i
looked at the baseline like how like if
i get 100 randomized trials in anything
how many randomized trials they expect
to be
garbage right dunk the sloppy uh frog
whatever
about twenty percent which is shocking
until you realize crazy well it's crazy
if you imagine which most people do that
the purpose of science is to figure out
what's taking place but what people
don't understand is that there is a
uh
substantial and hidden
landscape of perverse incentives right
academics are competing with each other
for grant money they're competing for
jobs and the ability to publish
something
somewhere is part of the key to getting
ahead so why are 20 of the studies you
know dead on arrival in terms of the
quality of the methods or what was
actually done
well it has a lot to do with the fact
that you get rewarded for publishing
something you don't necessarily get
rewarded for having done the job well
which slows it down and means you
publish fewer things in fact you get
punished for it so
anyway we did find we did find out uh
that there's a shocking level of of
garbage in
science but you're right the fact even a
fraud fraudulent trial uh doesn't say
anything about the trials that weren't
fraudulent these are independent pieces
of evidence and this is part of why some
of us have pointed to meta-analysis as a
better standard because unlike
the randomized controlled trial it's not
easily gamed and at the point that you
find out the study in your meta-analysis
isn't valid either because it's
methodologically flawed or fraudulent
you can just simply click it off and see
how it affects the analysis right it's a
robust method
so
anyway
there are many concerns here but i would
say if i was an editor who had published
this and i watched the authors refuse to
clarify
significant issues that were raised by
critics who are looking at the paper and
asking obvious questions
that would set off alarm bells
yep so so remember we talked about the
75 ghost patients
so there's another uh difference between
these patients um and this is uh
i find it quite humorous for reasons
i'll mention later but um
the it appears that the protocol that
changed on march 21st right um made a
change from the original protocol that
was in force in early january when the
when the previous batch of patients
including the 75 were recruited
um
the the original protocol cited sars
cove 2 vaccination as an enhancement
factor of your risk for whatever reason
which means that you are
you know if you have other basic uh
criteria met this is kind of the big one
you get included in the trial
so if you were vaccinated
in that period of early january until
early
march
if you were vaccinated and you showed up
at one of the trial centers in that
period of time
that was a reason to add you to the
trial
maybe they wanted data for that may i
can even come up with actually
reasonable explanation which is that um
maybe in brazil at that time they were
only vaccinating the high-risk patients
so
they're like this is kind of a proxy for
hires i don't know um but they would
they would add you to the trial
um
after march 21st
the vaccination switched from being an
inclusion uh reason to an exclusion
reason so if you were vaccinated they
say sorry we can't add you to our trial
this is like a pretty big you know so
some of the previous patients are
vaccinated
all of the later patients are not
vaccinated
so if
the issue of placebos and
treatments for ivermectin being disjunct
in time is what it appears to be right
then the change in protocol from an
inclusion criterion to an exclusion
criterion is absolutely fatal
now i know that the authors
have claimed it's just a typo am i
correct that that's not it's not the
author it's not the author absolutely i
i know listen to somebody uh some
somebody on the internet to claim
somebody on the internet some some
person on the internet uh who who is
is ever present when when uh this
certain molecule is discussed favorably
oh
well okay um so that's the best that's
the best critique we've seen that that i
mean it's so implausible basically that
what he ended up saying is that um this
is so crazy
that it could only be a time it could
only be no reason to believe it actually
happened which of course makes i mean
given that it's not the author who has
said it we shouldn't dwell here but it
makes no sense as a typo um
first of all it's hard to specify what
the typo would be in in in any case but
so what we've got then is an incredibly
important anomaly now i will point out
you could make an argument
for
vaccination as an exclusion criterion
you could make an argument for it as an
inclusion criterion what is absolutely
vital is that it does not change in a
way that uh separates the placebo group
from the treatment group right and we
appear to have the possibility here and
you can you know for those uh trying to
follow how this would have worked
to the extent that the vaccines have a
positive impact on uh one's trajectory
with covid
uh if you have a placebo group in which
people are uh
included
because they are vaccinated then they
will do
better than they might if they had been
unvaccinated and that will tend to make
the treatment look less effective so
another thing that people should be
tracking is okay it's a complex trial
there are lots of nuances the people
running the trial are discovering errors
that they make in real time and trying
to correct them but when all of the
errors go in one direction a direction
that would tend to make this particular
treatment um look ineffective even if it
was effective that raises questions in
and of itself right it's possible to
have errors that go in both directions
you would expect them to be equally
likely but when all of the errors go in
one direction
that again sets or should send up red
flags yep
and and you know this is basically what
we just described is kind of the heart
of the issue and it's kind of one of you
know
it's a cluster of errors uh that happen
around this one thing but i have a
hypothesis i don't know if it's worth
going into about what might have
happened
which is that um
there's a curious pattern about
how the allocation happens which is that
the the the algorithm that's allocating
seems to after early april
um balance what
the flavoxamine arm
so
you know on a certain date there's like
a certain number of patients in the
fuloximin arm there's a certain number
of patients in a placebo arm and there's
a certain number of patients on the low
dose plus high-dose ivormatic arm and
those numbers are within you know one or
two or three of each other right they're
very very close and they're kept closed
for the whole time
why would the total number of the
low-dose and high-dose diverting
patients
match
the number of fluvoximine patients and
placebo patients at the same time well
my hypothesis is that basically when
they stopped the low-dose hypermicron
arm or they halted it or whatever
however they told the algorithm don't
send patients there anymore
and when they brought it back
uh rather instead of saying like delete
it like forget about this or
stop it and then start a new one they
said we're bringing the old you know
start sending patients to a vermectin
again
and what that did is when the algorithm
sees the sort of the the the chunks it's
made along the way it's like wait
i've made you know little groups before
here that are short the patient now
because they have american thing that i
was supposed to sending patient would be
sending patients to
i wasn't doing that for a couple of
weeks so i got to go back and backfill
basically those little blocks i had made
of patients um
to to to make it all add up
and and you would do that right um when
you're coding one of these algorithms
because there's fluctuation because of
randomness you code it to recover you
code it to sort of see
differences between um
uh
where it should be and where it actually
is
and take actions to
rebalance because that could be
happening for all sorts of reasons this
is a massive change right there's a
massive difference that it should not
have been coded to recover from but i
can imagine algorithmically why you
would code it to have some self-healing
properties right and
self-healing properties are one thing
if it is coded not to imbalance between
the placebo and the treatment
right
in other words rebalancing the arms as
long as you don't unbalance the placebo
versus the treatment
um
could be done in a way that would not be
consequential
but
if you
uh
code your algorithms so that it just
tries to get back to the state that it
was targeted to deliver and that
unbalances you between the placebo right
and the treatment then it's uh again
another algorithm doesn't understand and
like it's think of a person in a black
box
literally giving letters to people like
you are group a group that doesn't know
about protocols doesn't know about
variance doesn't know about uh
you know it seems that it might not even
have known that the trial like it was
like a material difference between
before and after so it's just like hey
you know
you know
how we model computers right they are a
very efficient person who's not very
smart like they just do what they're
told so
i'm not saying that what it did was fine
i was saying is what i did was as
instructed
yeah
yeah it's uh how
yeah exactly so so anyway so that could
have happened or something else that i
don't know about but just
from my you know my my field of
expertise that from people for people
that might not know is in computing so
you know i i can imagine how i might
have done a coding error like that um
but again and again
to the extent that an error was made
like they programmed an algorithm in a
way that seemed reasonable but turned
out to have
consequences the only acceptable thing
for them to do is to acknowledge that
this has implications to share frankly
the algorithm
and
share the data that would allow us to
look at the consequences so that we
could adjust our understanding of their
conclusion exactly yeah so so that's
this is where you know i run out of good
faith explanations because
all of this could have happened for some
reason that was not necessarily
nefarious um it's it's it's like a you
know kind of a you know terrible
coincidence it's the middle of the
pandemic chaos whatever um but uh
from that point at some point it became
apparent right this is visible if i can
see it they can they can see it i don't
believe that they're that incompetent uh
so
they must have chosen at some point to
sort of obscure it to say like look
it's not a big deal
we'll just publish anyway um
well i would also
you know
or or you know
assuming the best here
well
i think you have to start out assuming
the best right it's not even necessarily
justified but it is the only practical
starting point that does not result in
chaos but the problem is
it is highly abnormal and scientifically
invalid to share the conclusion months
ahead of time to broadcast it at the
highest levels
and then
upon the release it's not even that they
broadcast the conclusions and the study
was good but we couldn't scrutinize it
for more than six months they broadcast
conclusions that were utterly black and
white in fact black and white far beyond
what's actually
written in the paper if you read it
carefully right the title does not match
what is in the paper but right
the
uh
the fact of that mismatch and the lack
of responsiveness to
the degree to which the conclusions
these black and white conclusions that
are not mirrored by what they actually
found
the the degree of mismatch and the lack
of of forthcomingness amounts to
something right first of all it is
as far as the philosophy of science goes
absolutely fatal to
the evidentiary nature of what they did
right not clarifying the degree to which
their conclusions are overstated because
their method doesn't reflect um
a proper randomization or control
we could take it as some kind of
evidence if we could correct for it but
if they're not going to give us the
information to allow us to correct for
it that is
scientifically speaking the end of the
evidentiary value here yep
and and by the way there's another
conclusion in here that i i resisted
early on and
do not like but i must highlight
so for the flavoxamine arm right first
of all the plant size was 681
patients they and they they go through
the the calculations of how they made
that specific number it sounds like okay
why like 681 but it comes out of a
mathematical calculation that they had
done earlier
um and the iraqi narrative indeed was
cut at 679 but the first fight you know
it's just too short uh that's fine um
but the fluvoxamine arm was allowed to
actually extend to
741 uh 742 in their original actually
and 741 in the published paper i don't
know what happened to the extra guy um
and then 756 placebo patients which is
you know and i think a nine percent
overrun in patients
um
and you might say like look you know
they they can't keep an eye on this all
the time so it's gonna overrun fine but
then the ever microphone was cut exactly
so exactly
they seem to have the capability to do
it for one thing but not for another
that's i i'm starting to get a little
bit curious here um and and and and the
the anomaly that we're talking about
right when we're saying that they over
allocated these patients who were
potentially more uh more diseased uh or
more likely to to to to have a negative
outcome to iron making that also means
they under allocated them to uh to
flavoxamine uh so they uh overlapped the
fluvoximin result as well they over
allocated patients to fluvoxamine and
under allocated
sickness
right yeah okay i mean this is this is
clear from the and also we're allocating
in the before times as well so they
don't have the imbalance between the
previous protocols so
we don't know anything about the intent
obviously it's a multi-authored paper
there may not even you know
to the extent that there are flaws here
they may owe to one person's
contribution or another but the point is
this the weird structuring right where
fluvoxamine gets an over allocation of
people
if one we're going to engineer a trial
to
reach an artificially
negative conclusion for a drug like
ivermectin
one way to do it is to if the trial is
unblinded is to shunt people into
another arm right in other words if you
see people who are disproportionately uh
likely to
survive or to not need hospitalization
and they show up in another arm then the
point is
uh you know a a knowing
experimenter
can
rig a trial in this way i'm not saying
anybody rigged this trial but the point
is the more anomalies like this you have
that allow somebody to
engineer a desired result
the more we have to ask the question if
that's what happened and unfortunately
in this environment we all know
that there was tremendous pressure right
those of us who talked about ivermectin
got tremendous uh blowback for even
mentioning the possibility that it
worked and so
what we have is an incentive
to find that result and we have
anomalies in this trial that would allow
a
uh
an engineering of that result that are
otherwise difficult to explain like why
would you over allocate
uh
patients to the fluvox amino so two two
points here first of all you're making a
great segue to something that um was
said in the in a recent uh presentation
of the results by the authors um i don't
remember the the person's name it's
frank something he says you know there's
a real question
whether we we cut this trial too short
in light of the political pressure to
show that ivermectin did not work so
this is not you saying that this is them
saying that right and that they cut it
short
but in light of the fact that they
didn't cut fluxuality flavox in fact
they let it well no i should say that
they stopped it at exactly the
prescribed time and they didn't you know
add a few more patients in fact mills
the the principal investigator uh in his
email to steve kersh said um
i actually think the result is positive
and it shows a 17 reduction in
hospitalization and
if we had only randomized a few more
patients i i believe that it would have
come out significant so this is
literally his quote this is this is
stunning
the principal investigator on this trial
this trial which has been
heralded from the rooftops as suggesting
that this drug has no effect the
principal investigator believes that the
trial showed
that it was not effective because they
didn't have enough patience that the if
he believes they saw an effect yep right
and that if they had randomized more
patients that that effect would have
been such that the conclusion would have
been different that is an amazing thing
to be true coming from the primary
author on a paper that the wall street
journal is telling us says ivermectin
doesn't work yep yep no it's it's um
it's it's kind of um i i don't know what
to say and and it comes in these
contradictions that we're hearing right
because the the wall street journal code
uh might say no effect whatsoever or no
indication
that uh ivermec works the emails say
other things the paper itself yet
seems to be have a split personality we
can go into that if you want well i do
think this is important and i remember
back from when the ivermectin arm result
was announced
seven or i guess it's closer to eight
months now is that right
um when that was
announced
the
poll quote was no effect whatsoever
which even at the time it was clear
wasn't true there was an effect the
question is was the effect large enough
that we could be sure it wasn't
statistical noise
but there was a positive effect it
wasn't no effect whatsoever and here you
have you know
seven or eight months later you have the
principal investigator saying he
believes they saw an effect that the
trial wasn't big enough to clarify it so
how is it
that journalists at the wall street
journal can't figure out that at at
worst what we have here is a result that
suggests ivermectin might work but the
trial wasn't large enough to spot it
yep yep
now it's worth mentioning that in in the
paper itself um they
and this is gonna it's throwing off
people constantly
um they do not
practice um frequentest statistics the
usual statistics the whole p-value
confidence interval crosses the one line
statistical significance that stuff
there is not a single mention of p-value
uh statistical significance or a
confidence interval in the whole paper
right this is this is crucial to
understand okay what did they do instead
they used i should say that that's not
bad that's probably i love it yeah i'm
i'm super pro but we have to understand
how to interpret it but the the benefit
comes from the interpretation not you
know
what it was um so they use instead uh
credible intervals and bayesian
statistics which is uh uh
well i'm gonna trigger some people and
i'm not a statistician my sense is that
it's more efficient at its use of
information to reach conclusion
um
and what so i i would i would argue you
tell me if you think this is wrong it is
more nuanced because
effectively we have a problem
which is that ultimately we're trying to
get to a
a binary result in a world of nuance
right you want to figure out whether
this is a drug you should or shouldn't
prescribe right and so you can do that
with a frequentist statistics and you
can say well this result you know
not only suggests an effect but it was
significant therefore we should
prescribe it or something like that
in the case of the bayesian statistics
you have uh a an ability to say well
how strong an effect did you see without
imposing that threshold up front yep yep
so so in the um so this trial one of
their sort of stylistic hallmarks in all
the papers they publish is to publish
these beautiful sort of bayesian uh bell
curves uh sort of and and how they
intersect to to to visually convey uh so
in the if they had a paper early on
hydroxycork and and uh le pena ver
retanovir maybe i didn't say that right
um and they and the flavoxamine paper
has the same thing the metformin paper
has the same thing the ever mechan paper
does not have that even though it's the
only paper that has exclusively painted
statistics
you have to go to the supplemental
appendix
download that go to a figure i believe
it is s2
and you will see something that will be
shocking
compared to the conclusions that stated
on you know on the first page which is
that um when they took the what they
call the intention to treat population i
think that's basically everybody um
they saw a
79.4
probability of superiority of ivermectin
over placebo even with all of the
caveats we discussed
in the modified intention to treat
population which i think is um
if let's say you you get added to the
ever marketing group
right but you have an event
on the first day
right they kind of know that that has
nothing to do with your
your your your your treatment so they
they take out some patients that weren't
really treated uh that shows 81.4
percent
possibility probability of superiority
uh of iraq and over uh so let me
understand what you're saying you're
saying there are some things that you
can spot along the way are not
informative
right yeah um some patients basically
are having their event way too close to
when they started taking to to to for
the event to be attributable to
what they were taking okay and so if you
clean that up you get above eighty
percent likelihood of superiority of
ivermectin over placebo yeah and then we
have to get to the even given
even given all of the structure that
shouldn't be there with people being
potentially recruited at different times
we must say though that the superiority
doesn't say how much superiority right
it could be a little experience it could
be a lot of security they don't get into
that in that particular analysis right
the event rate is lower right okay
yeah but even so you know those of us
who have been tracking the ivermectin
story
know this argument well right the fact
is you have
evidence of superiority and
unusual for this drug you have
an extremely low risk that is extremely
well understood because of the long
period of time over which this drug has
been prescribed and the large number of
people to whom it's been given i i i
should mention right that we should
expect the results that we see to be
fairly the difference we see to be
fairly
narrow because of all the things that we
described
if we did not see the the difference
being narrow
we
we would lose everything we know about
our mechanics so so we know that they
gave the drug
i believe the median
time was five days after symptoms
so half the patients were more half the
patients were less and there's some
question around that number i don't want
to get into because we're going to be
talking another this is another 20
minute conversation but
we know that when you take that kind of
population there's there's quite likely
an additional day of delay between they
actually
actually got the drug if we if we put it
on the sort of the dose response the
timing uh sorry the time response curve
that we know about early treatments we
expect about a 40
uh improvement right so when we have
certain
circumstances we expect the result to
you know the 17 that uh mills quoted is
not shocking to anybody it's like
when you know you know three or four
factors that went into those results
that's what you'd predict
so
i hope someday
the full story of what took place with
early treatment especially ivermectin
and hydroxychloroquine and covid
is sorted out by a team with resources
to really dig and access to information
after the
the
disincentive for honesty has dissipated
i hope we ultimately get the full story
because what this sounds like to me is
the deck was stacked by the house and
they still lost
right if you look at what they actually
discovered the point is there were all
kinds of reasons that should have
dampened the effect of iremecht and to
the point of being useless and yet they
still saw an effect and this isn't the
first time we've seen that right
one thing that's on my mind i want to
make sure i cover is the 681 number
right um this number was uh determined
uh based on the background rate of
events like
based on their primary endpoint um in in
the period at the time in the region at
the time
um but
on that background they were pla they
were what they were
tuning in to do was to spot a 37 and a
half
percent effect right so you you you're
this is what you're sort of assuming if
it's less than that you have you know
you have statistical power issues with
eighty percent power
um that's what they so when they come
out and say basically no effect
whatsoever no indication whatever no but
you what you tuned your study to do is
find
with eighty percent statistical power
thirty seven and a half percent so if
you have a drug that is thirty seven and
a half uh percent effective you expect
four out of five times if i understand
the notion of physical power correctly
to to catch it to find it that's that's
what the that's what they that's what
they did in fact they were kind of
criticized in an open peer review about
that size they're like this is
you you're you're aiming to find too too
big in effect too you know too low the
power why aren't you like you know
ramping it up a little bit um
and you know the the author sort of the
primal principle investigator
you know his response was kind of
dismissive to those comments from the
invited reviewers um but that's what
they were that that's what if we if we
strictly interpret what they found
that's what they did not find a 37.5
um
effect in a trial that had 80
statistical power
right that's that's what happened
that's what happened and just so
essentially what you're talking about is
a bayesian version
of what typically happens with a
frequentist where they find an effect
and it doesn't reach significance and
they report that there was no effect
we've seen that before in in ivermectin
as elsewhere but the point is in in this
case it's in a different language
because it's bayesian statistics and not
frequentist but it's the same problem we
can see if we look at what they actually
found that in spite of many biases all
of which go in one direction they did
find an effect a notable one and when
you compare this i mean let's not lose
track of what we're actually trying to
discover
is this drug worth giving to people
uh who have covet right right now if the
answer to that question was yes then you
would likely do what we've seen done all
over the world what we've seen done in
india what we've seen done in mexico
where basically people are given access
to this very safe drug very early in
many cases even before they've had a
positive test right and so the point is
this study
looks at them yeah it's not the latest
administration of uh ivermectin that
we've seen but nonetheless these are
people who are deeply into disease these
aren't people who at the first hint of
disease have been given this drug and
are given it with a meal that has fat in
it to facilitate it's getting into the
bloodstream right and we have these
methodological issues where
it appears that sicker people are likely
to have ended up in the placebo arm i
mean in the in the iremectin arm and
healthier people were liable to end up
in the placebo arm
all of these things go in the same
direction and yet we still see a notable
effect that even the author the primary
author of the study says he believes
indicates the drug works and that if
they had added more people to the trial
that it would have passed their
statistical test to right
now
in the article and i'll leave it up to
you if you want to go into that there's
i discussed two more factors that would
have dampened the effects um one is that
the high dosing as described was not
actually high enough uh we can go into
that and the other one was the
background use of ivermectin in brazil
at the time
yeah these are tremendously important we
should we should talk about them
okay so um
let's go into the dosing so remember
what they had done with the low dose
where they had put the this arbitrary
limit at 60 kilograms whatever i have
enough i've not found any literature
anywhere that describes a weight limit
forever mechanic for any tree for
treatment of anything if you go to the
nih website and look for strongholdus or
whatever it says go scale it by scale it
by your weight full stop there's no like
until
right um
so they had the 60 kilogram limit limit
when they when they moved it up and
moved up the dose they they changed it
to a 90 kilogram limit
right um
90 kilogram limit um based on the
average height a brazilian man as as a
found some reports say 171 once some
reports say 173
that means that they're they're they're
given that by the way the trial had half
low bmi patients under 30
that's not low but anyway
and half hot
this has this is high very high yeah um
now around 30 bmi around 174 height is
90 kilograms right 91 kilograms to be
precise so it's it's um almost half the
men in the trial
um
in the high dose trial
would have had their dose start slipping
under this 400 uh mcg per kg
and about i'm assuming about a third of
the women uh because you know their
their bmi is higher for lower for lower
weights so they would that would not
have caught them at that level but uh
later um and and and this is that this
pernicious effect where high bmi is high
risk right so the higher your risk the
lower your dose
this is weird like
and and
what frustrates me with this is
you want to answer the question for once
and for all right this is how the the
trial is heralded like why do stuff like
this why there's there's no clinical
explanation i from what i've heard from
the author's camp from people informally
um
there's no real reason for this why
right why it it it's it's unthinkable
right and one can
speculate but there's no justification
for it but if you were looking for a way
to underpower a trial
that was
somewhat subtle that didn't show up in
the oh well what dose did they use right
if your first question is well yeah i've
seen these under trial underpowered
trials before what dose did they use
right and that threshold will be missed
by many people maybe many journalists
it has no justification and the point is
because covid is the or the severity of
kovid
is so significantly correlated to bmi
then the point is
this is a a critical failure this is a
critical failure the people who are
likely to get sickest are the most
underdosed yep right yeah i i can't i
can't explain it there's no
again there's no medical justification
that i've seen it it just makes no sense
and in fact
there's something there's some issue i
can't quite describe i mean if you think
about comparing it to placebo
right the point is the placebo is flat
and the degree of underdosing
goes up and up the heavier you are and
the more vulnerable to covet you are
uh there's it's just
uh uh it's it's an unthinkable failure
and the thing is okay maybe they've got
a great reason for that
let's hear it
yep
i mean there's just not there's not
there's not
literature there i think that one is is
one when i had a chance to ask a
question of one of the authors of the
paper this is the one i asked
and i got told to uh you know follow the
process and be professional
um
yeah all right
um there was another issue you wanted to
to cover yep so
the other issue was that uh
there was we know uh background use of
ivermectin in the population
in in brazil in the particular region uh
of ministeries the the the the the
the the region of brazil and bela
horizonte the city um so we know there
was a background news of america why uh
first of all
this might sound surprising to people it
was the official government recommended
treatment
wow um
so
the the the now this was being fought by
the sort of the medical establishment so
the government went ahead and
promote promoted this thing called
kitkovit which had i believe hydrox
corquin ever met and as it's promising a
few other things maybe some vitamins um
and
the best i could find is that 25 of the
population used them at some point
um but it was being fought hard so just
to give you a sense uh a brazilian
investigator we both know that's looking
into these trials when i asked him was
this like trump he's like no no it was
much worse so
just to understand the severity of the
hatred uh that the establishment had for
uh bolsonaro who who was promoting this
this treatment um and yeah i mean this
is the tragedy of this of this of this
molecule right it's been sort of
politicized to hell and back um anyway
so so um
there was availability over the counter
first of all of the of the medicine it
was being promoted by the government as
a as part of a kit
um was it you would expect sorry was it
free i'm not sure i'm not sure how the
kid was promoted you'd expect but i
don't i don't know
um that would be that would be worth
knowing because obviously it changes the
incentive of somebody to join the trial
right i i believe the um the over the
counter i ever met in in brazil was like
five bucks and a five bucks for us is
not five bucks for brazil but it's it's
not going to be you know the number is
like you know it's it's not a hundred um
you know you can scale it could be
the effect of 20 bucks or whatever right
uh in in for a low income brazilian
household um
but that number is still you know if
you're sick
this will help you you would you would
probably find it
um
anyway so
we also know from local press that was
not friendly to every mechanism
that in the particular state of minister
ace around the period of the study
especially around that sort of march
april um
time time frame
use of avermectin had increased
nine times
over the background
nine times um so significant use i've
seen i've actually seen myself have seen
numbers that indicate from 2019
the race is more like 20 times i i don't
i'm not a liberty to share them because
they're proprietary numbers from a
company that
gathers them from pharmacies but
take whichever number you like 9 20 what
does it matter a lot
so when you say over background you mean
over the rate that people are using it
for parasites for parasites yeah which
was which was minimal it wasn't like i
mean i mean if you see graphene there's
that 20 20 times difference you the
the low number will will seem low but um
yeah so it was
you know a big big difference in the use
um so we know there was background use i
mean
you know what how else do we explain
these numbers and again the the the the
local publication that said nine times
was all in the same problem in the same
piece says there's concerns about safety
etc etc which is the usual talking
points so these are not people who are
promoting it or they're worried that
it's nine times right um
so
when the original results came out in
august right the sort of the one slide
sort of presentation they mentioned the
exclusion criteria and they did not
mention
uh checking if people were taking every
method when they were added to the trial
and this is bad because placebo group
and treatment group might have a
background some of them might be taking
it or make them might not know
the
investigators did not say anything at
the time this was a key criticism
throughout you know the drum beat was
like
you didn't put an exclusion criteria
obliques when the paper came out you
know the first thing i did i go to the
to the paper where it says exclusion
criteria no mention of americans says
like go here for more i go there for
more no excuse for ever mexican i'm like
oh wow they still haven't
it turns out there is a single sentence
in the description in the discussion
sorry of the papers like some some in
some other place which you don't put
exclusion criteria in by the way this is
not normal
um
that says we screened extensively
for use of iron actin for covid
right and the investigator whenever he
says he says four covet and i'll go into
why this is significant um
and
uh you know we removed those people and
he also mentioned in in one of the
emails something that confused the hell
out of me which was like if you were
taking one of the drugs you might be
allocated another arm
what
anyway i i i choose to ignore that
because it's the repercussions are so
preposterous as to just you know we
already have enough to worry about um so
but they they basically say that to to
mean that yes we did exclude people now
why is that not uh
they
said they might have allocated people to
a different arm if they were taking a
drug in the excluded in the exclusion
criteria that's what there's there's a
foreign
for example then
people who might be comparing fluvox i
mean and i have a right
right
wow
that raises all kinds of questions
i i i i i it's so it's so such a big
thing that i i just you know i i for
some reason i'm
uh
he might be there's some part i don't i
don't know i just don't want to go into
that it's just it's so so
i i choose to take it as an offhand
remark that might have been um uh
misunderstood or something we have
enough on our plate but that was weird
um
but but but here's why it matters the
way they articulated what they did
right um so when we look at the forms
that the patients filled in when they
were added to the trial there's you know
that you go through the exclusion
criteria there's nothing about every
micron i think there's like a known
hypersensitivity if you're like allergic
or something that's not what we're
talking about
but there is
a appendix which is like concomitant
medication so other drugs you're taking
right so if you're taking blood pressure
meds or like whatever it is
they want you to write it down
and under that they have indication why
you're taking it
um
so in theory
somebody would have written ivermectin
why covet right not parasites um
and you could have caught it
however we're talking about a trial
where the data collection were so
compromised
uh there's 331 patients 23
that they're not sure how long since
symptoms started they're missing they're
missing for a good i believe it's a
double-digit percentage the age
of the patients right again we're and
again this you can make this make sense
right early stage italy chaos whatever
you're doing what you can you're getting
rough ages from people you're like you
look adults right because it's like if
you if you don't know the age
theoretically how do you know they're
adults how do you know they can even be
in the trial right you i i can i can
make that all that makes sense but you
can't convince me of that
and that they went and recorded all the
medications you're taking and the
precise reasons why you're taking them
and the the investigator says
and by the way there wasn't much use
in the area
okay so you didn't catch like a ton of
people so you may
not much use in the area when we have
other evidence that there was lots of
use in the area
um a weird phenomenon it shouldn't
matter from the point of view of the
experiment whether you were taking it
for covet or not the question is were
you on the drug or weren't you and so
the exclusion criterion even to the
extent that it existed is bizarre from
the point of view of actually testing
iremectin
um
so
and then there's a
yeah it raises all kinds of questions
for me it also raises a question you
know we've talked about the unblinding
of the trial from the point of view of
the experimenter which is dangerous
but it's also possible that the trial
was unblinded either accidentally or not
so accidentally from the point of view
of the patients right so for example
um you know ivermectin has a
flavor to it and a patient might get the
sense that they are either on the drug
or on the placebo from that that could
be an honest error but my understanding
from the paper
is that they showed
um
patients in the trial
a video
to sort of orient them right a video
that was presumably in portuguese
and
discussed what the patient would
experience and yes one could put
together a perfectly
well constructed video that would leave
things perfectly blinded but if you were
looking to wink at patients so that
they would
self-treat if they found themselves in
the placebo group because they had
joined the study in hopes of getting a
medication that many thought worked
[Music]
that could also
produce an effect so in some sense among
the many things that we would need to
see in order to know that this trial was
valid is well can we see the video right
there's even one more thing that is
harder to characterize statistically
it dawned on me as i was kind of
discussing these results which is that
say you have a background population of
people in brazil using aeromechtin and
let's say everybody works differentially
in people right and some people it works
and some people it doesn't um and so
let's say that the people that it does
work don't go to the hospital and the
people that it doesn't work do go to the
hospital right and and you are now
looking at applicants so even if you
didn't catch it even if you did exclude
it even if you did all the things you
are still looking at a subset of the
population that could potentially be
less suitable to that treatment whatever
but the fact that even if they did
exclude given the background use in the
population
already
you know changes the the meaning of
these results and again i don't know
what precise statistical bias this this
would be
but
it's
one thing that continually frustrates me
with the
authors is that i think some of the
things we have seen not everything but
some of them could have been resolved
with just more openness right being
saying look we changed the dose because
of this we changed it at that date we
you know just be clear about what
happened so we can move on and find the
most the more important things there's
this general refusal
to engage to you know like an
adversarial relationship i can
understand it even to a point i know
there's people on both sides of this
conversation that are very emotional
they're very aggressive they can get you
know i mean you've definitely sensed
that on the side of you know uh
the pro side there's definitely people
on the anti-side that sense you know
a lot of sort of aggression etc but
we're doing science right we're not
we're supposed to try to
walk that out and do our work as best as
we can and there's this
adversarial sort of relationship between
they they mentioned constantly sort of
advocacy groups and
they even mentioned paramedical groups
which i don't understand what it is
paramedics performing groups unclear um
but
um
you know
i
i understand the emotional sort of
tension around all of this but as
scientists we're supposed to
try as much as we can to put that aside
and and just come out with the results
become what may right uh reveal the
world is as clear as we can
and and and the authors seem to be very
aware of the context let's just let's
just put it that way
um
some of these things might have been
clarified but but we're not we're not
getting signal
right to the point that mills discusses
the
uh
the pressure
right yeah
no it wasn't mills but mills
after this person said it he says i
completely agree with frank what's mill
said mill said that okay so um
[Music]
so there is one final bit to all of this
that has to be mentioned
which is that in these adaptive trials
there is this data and safety
uh monitoring board committee they come
with different names but what they do
is because perhaps as a safeguard right
because perhaps because all of this
stuff is possible
there's supposed to be an independent
committee that
as the name implies looks at the data
is primarily concerned about safety of
the patients
and you know monitors sort of the trial
to make certain decisions about where to
stop things looks at the interim
analyses um you know all these decisions
that we've seen about sort of extension
of certain things or or cutting short
normally you would expect them to go
through this committee which is supposed
to be independent and indeed in their
papers they say you know it's
independent committee okay
you look at who's in this committee
and um the chairman is a person called
christian thorland uh christian thorland
um
is has published more than 100 papers
with ed mills who is the principal
investigator right they're academic sort
of soulmates let's call it um
more than 100 i mean most people don't
have 100
papers um they published 100 papers
together
and you i dug in a little bit deeper
if you go to the together trial website
on the wayback machine and you go to the
first version
you will see that
mills and thorland are cited as co-lead
investigators of the trial so
thorland is on the side of you know the
people designing the child if you look
at where the email goes of saying you
know where do i get information it goes
to a company called m-tech sciences
anti-sciences is a startup in fact that
was founded by
edward mills and christian ireland my my
guess is that amtec means mills thorland
uh edward christian uh i'm tech right um
but it might not but the thing is like
it is founded by them it was acquired by
seitel the company that does a
statistical analysis uh for the
for this
study
another person was working at mtech and
moved to sciatica as per the acquisition
called jonas hackstrom he's also
in the data and
and safety
uh monitoring committee um and you're
like okay so
all of these people have very good
reason to want uh the trial to succeed
and produce whatever results mills you
know wants and
are unblind they are unblinded right so
they see the data and they can make
decisions on the data um and they're not
independent uh there's and and two more
of the members of the committee have got
you know 25 and nine papers written
together with mills less of a severe
thing but like when you already have
uh two big pieces especially the
chairman of the committee being uh
linked like inextricably i would say at
this point like they started starting
together they're working at saito
they're working at mcmaster university
they've got 100 papers you know they're
like this they're they're soulmates
right there's no
the the distinction is is thin
um now okay you might say i don't know
what you might say this is not good
but in the open peer review that
happened in august
two of the invited reviewers that made
the other the other they asked about the
power of the study was also we're also
asking
they they made this note they didn't
catch all of the context but just to see
that this person works as i tell this
person is a is that mcmaster samus mills
this is not good um and they said look
this isn't right and we are withholding
our full approval
of the protocol based on this one thing
mills comes back and said
i will i'm happy to take away his vote
in the committee so they removed the
vote but kept him as chairman
right
and didn't do anything for hacks
so the reviewers on the basis of that
what they consider the lackluster
response said i'm sorry um this is not
sufficient um if they want a
statistician they can call them in the
room they to do to give them some advice
and walk out he cannot be in the room
when the discussion is happening
therefore we are withholding our full
approval of the protocol on the basis of
the lack of independence of the data and
safety monitoring committee now so
we have
just to put it in context right we have
all of these irregularities happening in
the trial the people who are involved in
many of those decisions and who are
supposed to be sort of the safeguard the
the
the people who can say like look there
was those other people that had nothing
to do with the authors that made a lot
of those decisions it's not the problem
these people are very closely linked
so at that point yeah i i don't know
what's left of the
trial and what we can make of the
results because
there's there's so much room for
maneuver right it becomes a matter of
trust
to the investigators and the whole
reason we're doing rcds in the first
place is to remove bias
so
what are you know what's even happening
right
you are being too generous i can tell
you on the basis of the underlying
philosophy of science
that
the number of anomalies
that we
are unable
we should be able from the description
in the published paper to reconstruct
what happened to the extent that that is
not possible we should be able to
request information that would allow us
to fill in any gaps that we cannot
ourselves
fill in based on what is published and
to the extent that that is not provided
it is fatal now it's not to say that
they couldn't then come back with
information that would explain what
these anomalies are in some satisfactory
way but
it is almost impossible for me to
imagine
what the answers would be that would
cover all of these anomalies and to the
extent that this was not
randomized or placebo controlled in a
valid way
that it may have been unblinded on the
for researchers i think we know less
about what happened with patients a lot
less but that that possibility also
exists this is not evidence science
depends on the work being done properly
so that the conclusions that we derive
are robust right this is
the deductive part of the process to the
extent that the assumptions are not met
the deductive conclusion is not valid
and we can even see that in the fact
that what is reported is not even
consistent with what is presented within
the data so
it is not a valid study if it can't
recover from these things and the
refusal to try is conspicuous um from
the point of view of what sort of
evidentiary value it has i would say it
has zero value until these things are
clarified
you know and and i i i mean this is this
is my sense as well though though
i find it interesting that it it its
actual results with
plus the context match roughly what we'd
expect um you know given all of the the
watering down this is about you know
what you you'd expect to see
but um
the
to me the the the real
issue to me right it could be real
issues for others what animates me in
this whole debate
is that you know we can't have isolated
demands for rigor we can't have rigor
for thee but not for me this cannot be
allowed to stand
we can decide different rule sets
there's some play right what exactly are
going to be the rules we can discuss
that what we can discuss is that
you know henry carvalho a retired you
know doctor in argentina is being put
through the wringer for
arguably doing a sloppy study um but
people who are very well funded with you
know a staff and statisticians and you
know a pr agency and
the papers written you know being the
best journals get a different treatment
sorry like no
right
this is where i draw the line so yes and
let me let me point something out uh you
raised the carville question um
carvajo did a very sloppy study
i do not believe there is any evidence
that it was
dishonest but i will point out that i
had thought the carvaja study was an
important piece of evidence
and when i asked for the data and did
not get it
and
discovered over time that what had
happened was a tally rather than the
careful collection of data that would
have immunized the study from various
kinds of bias there was an informal
tally that was kept
that suggested a very powerful result
i went on to darkhorse and i said look
this has
zero evidentiary weight it doesn't mean
they didn't see the effect that they say
they saw but it means that we cannot
look at this as a carefully run study
that indicates what the conclusions that
we've been given are so the point is
that is the right thing to do is to look
at a study that is compromised and say
because i can't reconstruct exactly what
happened here zero evidentiary weight
right that is the right thing to do with
at least the ivermectin arm of the
together trial
and i would argue based on what uh
you've revealed here in passing with
respect to the fluvoxamine arm etc that
we have to wonder about the whole thing
zero evidentiary value unless we can see
that a study of robust methodology was
correctly carried out and resulted in
conclusions that match what's being
presented that would have to be the
minimum and we're nowhere near that so
people should recognize the right thing
to do as it was with kervaio is to say
this is not evidence right scientist so
as i've said many times on darkhorse
science is a very powerful process but
it is fragile
it depends on the philosophy of science
being robust it depends on the absence
of powerful financial and other
incentives pushing people towards some
conclusions it depends on the equal
application of rigor as you point out
all of these things have to be true in
order for the evidence uh to be useful
to us and
this is so far from where we are with
respect to ivermectin generally and this
trial in specific that
one really has to
uh
to wonder how we get ourselves out of
here have we so corrupted our scientific
structure that it is incapable of
allowing us to see
and and of course there is also the
surrounding theater around the study
right there are not one but three new
cycles
powered by the way in which the results
were released so on august 6th
i mean i find this kind of shocking
honestly the remaining arm is supposed
to end on august 6. the same day
like literally i mean some day
the speed
is stunning right it's august 6th
they come out you know the the deck is
is is is is is dated august 6. um with
the results
okay amazing right great um and indeed
for philosophy by august 23rd we've got
the pre-print and you know a couple
months later it appears in in lansing
for iraq you know quiet no preprints no
data nothing then um a couple of weeks
before its release we get a wall street
journal uh exclusive right um look and
people who had seen the study not you
know not me not you not uh you know
somebody who might know a little bit
more about but it might be skeptical but
people who were uh you know
uh helpful to the story that was being
created um had seen the study and were
making comments and and then that wall
street journal triggered you know its
own little uh you know uh waves
um and then two weeks later again uh the
study gets released new york times
headlines you know doesn't work blah
blah blah and of course then it's
matched with the calls that
at some point we have to
wonder
should we keep studying this thing is it
is it is it worth at this point you know
we got so much evidence so controvers so
incontrovertible right
what are we why are we even wasting
research dollars on this question
anymore like you so you you use that as
a platform to sort of say not only this
evidence is final but like stop
collecting evidence as a whole
and and that's where again you start to
wonder and that does not have to be the
authors but it could be somebody who is
working with the authors or or even just
taking what the authors are putting out
and amplifying it
um
what's happening especially because when
you actually see the data so my advice
to people just on twitter and everywhere
else when you see a study
wait a couple of weeks
seriously like i've made this mistake
lots of us have
you have to control your first instinct
to just um come out and and make grand
conclusions uh about a study uh ask
questions be with you see this is
interesting whatever but like hold
something back
for at least a couple of weeks because
once it gets examined and this is again
on the pro and the anti side right it
doesn't have to be
about a specific study this is about all
studies um you have to wait at least a
couple of weeks to see what emerges
because
as there is the formal scientific
process these days there's a collective
intelligence on the other side that is
also absorbing cross-checking
contextualizing things and things emerge
that you just like this like
again the the conclusions that we've
we're coming to for this trial
are as um
implausible as they are undeniable
it is just baffling all right so
the um
i i'm not sure exactly how to convey
this
it is non-standard to emerge into public
with the conclusions of a study that is
not going to be published
for half a year at the very least people
should be able to scrutinize a draft at
that moment to get a sense for where the
authors are even if the thing is going
to take time to go through the pipeline
to give us the conclusion
to sensationalize the conclusion
to delay our ability to scrutinize
the work itself if all of those things
are true the work better be
pretty close to spotless right it should
be exceedingly high quality work not
shoddy work right if you're going to
trumpet this in the wall street journal
if you're going to gaslight us for more
than half a year over the conclusions of
this trial before we get to see how it
even
worked the trial better be incredibly
high quality instead what we have
is
frankly it's a mirror of the
problem
that we saw
uh with cold fusion right it's it's
science by press release by press
conference right that's what this was
and
you know as with cold fusion what
actually emerged in the aftermath when
we got to see uh the details it wasn't
supportive of the sensational headline
so this is in some sense
uh a case of you know ivermectin and
cold confusion right what we've got
is um
the purpose
somebody's purpose here is about
headlines and not about discovery
and the discovery here is i would say
exceedingly low quality
right this is not high quality science
it's certainly not worthy of the new
england journal of medicine hard to
imagine how the editors themselves
didn't spot the numerous inconsistencies
and problems
let alone the peer reviewers how did
this go you know
a process that had an extra six months
to get this stuff right should be
especially clear and good rather than
especially opaque and full of obvious
holes yeah the authors indicated that
the journal gave them trouble in in
publication though they indicated as
being exasperated that they didn't
sort of make the obvious connection that
maybe they were seeing something you
didn't like um but also there's there's
an indication that the corresponding
author changed in february which is
strange like who is the who what hap
what what's going you know this is not
common
not it is uncommon and i would also
point out okay if the journal gave them
a hard time presumably the things that
the journal gave them a hard time about
were fixed
before it went to publication that means
that the many many flaws ambiguities and
dangers that are apparent in what they
published are the things that got
through right so the work was even more
compromised than this apparently
you see most of the issues when you put
humpty dumpty together when you when you
when you take them at form and paper the
fluvoximing paper and they're making a
paper and you
uh you assemble them
is is when the discontinuities the paper
the aramaic paper itself when read in
isolation there's still questions
there's still concerns but
you know if you had nothing else it
would be hard to to challenge it
definitely not at this level
yep
um with
which
i don't know it's a fascinating
condition let's just say that
all right um there's
a lot in
your
article on this that we have not covered
i would certainly encourage people to
look at it carefully
um
we're no doubt going to get feedback
maybe we'll discover that some of the
issues that have been raised are
less critical than we think maybe we
will discover that there are issues that
we didn't discuss that are important and
should be explored but at the very least
i
would say
it is beyond time for
the authors of this study
to
hand over the information they have so
we can clarify what actually took place
and therefore what if any evidentiary
value exists in this study
yeah i think as as um we've kind of said
before um
even
now you can sort of hold a
you know some level of uncertainty as to
what happened and why some sort of you
know superposition of of of theories
hypotheses
um but i i think what happens with the
data is the razer that separates these
entwined hypotheses for me
uh what happened with the data and the
lack of forthcomingness what happens
from not like what happens from this
point if the authors
are say okay no you guys are wrong you
know here it is
um
you know and here's how here's why these
discontinuities appear
um
you know
we can discuss like we could be wrong
but there's always that chance we should
we should i don't understand how i mean
this is basic addition subtraction that
i'm doing i'm not good doing statistics
but there could be some let's say
innocent errors that were misunderstood
or whatever it is or uh it could be
something that like some kind of a
confusion whatever
but if the data is not forthcoming i
think we
we have to note right that again
carvalho is a retired doctor the people
here the the the sort of the roster of
authors
is has an over-represented group of
professional clinical trial designers
for big pharmaceutical companies this is
what they do they don't mess up on
studies by accident it's hard to believe
and and i don't want to go heavy on the
conflict of interest part right
people can definitely assume that i
can't prove anything what i can prove is
that these people are supposed to know
how to run a perfect trial or well
nobody does
let us also recognize this is not
some college paper
right this is
a global pandemic and an important
question about a medication that either
does or does not save lives to the
extent that you run a study i don't care
how expensive it is i don't care how
fancy it was
if it turned out that the method
collapsed on you because of things maybe
you couldn't foresee
you don't publish it
yeah right to the extent that they ran a
shoddy study even if it was well
intended even if it was the complexity
that got him in the end you don't
publish the study as if it's evidence if
it isn't and if it is evidence then you
provide the data so that we can
scrutinize it
and uh not have to guess where the
bodies are right right right yeah some
somebody who was i was uh
review
got his help reviewing a professor at
the university of canada um who reviewed
the paper with me uh just to sort of
again i have stanley checked it with a
lot of people right the reason for my
confidence such as it is uh is that i've
done that but one of uh these people
said
um that you know the word farmicon in
greek not not pharma flarmicon
is a dual word right it's poison and
cure at the same time and i know this is
in modern greek there's still that
duality in in the word
um and and the point is that you know
with knowledge of how to cure comes
knowledge of how to poison so this is to
me the key question right was the
knowledge that the authors had
uh used in a reverse fashion
was this a chaotic situation because of
pandemic and maybe a
polishing airbrushing of things
afterwards to make it look like nothing
happened uh the data will answer that
question i think pretty pretty clearly
well that's a
fascinating point to end on because i
guess the way to say it is we are told
randomized controlled trials are the
gold standard
because of their power
to reveal
subtle patterns but the knowledge of how
to
run a randomized controlled trial is
also the knowledge of how to game a
randomized controlled trial and in an
environment where there's as much
at stake as there is surrounding
ivermectin
uh with the number of anomalies we see
it is absolutely fair and in fact it is
our obligation to wonder what happened
here
[Music]
all right well alexandros morenos uh
i want to thank you for
doing
this work i know you have a new baby and
you're pressed for time and i
you know this is not
your profession so i really appreciate
all of the work you put into sorting out
what took place and writing it up in a
way
that uh makes very difficult material
accessible and i want to thank you for
joining me here and uh
discussing it
um it's been fascinating i must say
thank you for having me hopefully this
will get us some answers and that this
work was not just me i've tried to name
several people that helped in that
conversation there's a lot of people
that help that i i i can't name or i
don't even know the names because
there's this emerging sort of
social media uh ecosystem that generated
you know a lot of leads some of them
dead ends but um
the the i feel like i'm sitting at the
top of an elephant that was far far
greater than myself
yeah yeah a tremendous number of people
uh worked to to try to sort out what was
going on and so yes i think it makes a
great deal of sense to to thank them
for their hard work some of them have
been working uh from early on in the
pandemic collecting evidence some of
them are anonymous i think because they
are afraid of what happens
um if they reveal themselves
uh
all right um anyway it's been very
interesting and i look forward to seeing
what uh what we learn from here on out
thank you very much all right see what
happens be well everyone